[Music]
let's go to caitlin in
west palm beach florida what's up
caitlin
hi dr d how are you i just want to say
i'm really excited i'm excited i'm
talking to you a little nervous um i
followed you from the very beginning
super honored that you would even take
my call
well i'm grateful for you that's uh it's
really kind that you even reached out
and lucky for you you may get some
cocaine energy even though i'm not doing
drugs
listen like james said i'm super jealous
because
you have to buy your drugs
yeah i mean coffee starbucks is like the
equivalent of street prices anyway
[Laughter]
exactly and the lines are longer hey so
what's up caitlin
okay so
i had coveted about a month ago
how are you
how are you
i'm much better now good was it pretty
rough
it was very rough mentally more so than
physically i
assumed because i had the vaccine it was
like a breakthrough
but mentally i already struggled with
anxiety already struggled with ptsd
um and this whole experience was just
you know when people ask me about it i
just say it was really traumatic yeah it
was traumatic for me
um
since then
i have developed
ocd is what i've been told um
specifically contamination ocd
oh man are you germaphobing out like
crazy i am like yeah full on
um
like doorknobs
freak me out and
buttons and
you know just
yeah it's all about either germs or
getting sick again or getting someone i
love sick or other people sick
yes um
i've never dealt with this problem
before i've never had these feelings or
thoughts or worries in this way before
um
i do have to say that it has
eased up a little bit
since like the initial you know coming
out of kovid
but
i just can't shake the like
you know in the back of my mind i'm
always thinking i'm always thinking
about the buttons always thinking about
the doorknobs i'm always thinking you
know absolutely
you know
of course the doctor is one to throw
medicine at me but i just kind of feel
like i would rather
i feel like i have the mindset and the
willpower to work through this
you know
i've sought therapy i've been told to
try
exposure therapy with no
you know real explanation of how to do
that and
so yeah i'm just hoping
i gotcha where there's a will there's a
way right i got you uh sort of sort of
okay um i
but it's gonna work exactly opposite of
how you think it is so let me ask you
two questions real quick to help me
frame this
um
anxiety what's what's what is that
trying to tell you
do you have childhood trauma what's the
psd ptsd from
i have childhood trauma and then i have
a
significant other we're not married but
you know we have a kid and all that um
who has a substance abuse problem and a
lot of stuff with him okay all right so
you've got
so the way i frame anxiety and i'm gonna
walk you i'm gonna reverse engineer
where we are okay the way um
the best i can tell biochemically and um
both biochemically and relationally
anxiety is just an alarm you may have
heard me say this a thousand times
that tells your body you're either out
of connection with the relationships
so it's an ancient it's an ancient alarm
system letting you know you just woke up
on the planes and you were all by
yourself and you were probably gonna die
so it wants you to reconnect the second
one is the alarm that is letting you
know you are not in control of your
situation you are out of control
somebody else has autonomy over you
and then the third one is just a
generalized alarm that says you're not
safe right now
and one i just want to tell you really
quickly is that um the anxiety
that i feel now it's almost as if you
know when i had the covid i was so hyper
sensitive of what am i feeling what are
my symptoms what's going to happen
what's not happening you know to
i was on this like high alert
and it's almost like i can't turn it off
now yes okay so here's the beautiful
thing about the system and it's
devastating at the same time it's like
watching an explosion it's so beautiful
and it just is so destructive
um
when you
and it could be a hundred things from
your childhood i'm gonna pick one
randomly and just go from there okay
uh but you know this runs deeper than
what i'm about to say
so
you're in relationship with an addict
and you're trying to make it work and
sometimes you participate and sometimes
you don't so you get shame and guilt too
and then you have a kid and then you
have this picture of what my life was
going to look like with a kid and it is
anchored to an addict
and so the boat you are on is rocking
always it's never stable and underneath
all of that you have lost
control
and your brain begins to tell you every
day we got to get control back we got to
get control back we got to get control
back and then you've got some patterns
that you learned as a child which is
either hide or to over correct
and i when i just said over correct
think of a steering wheel your hands
just some people when the when they hit
hit um they're about to have a wreck
they literally let go of the wheel the
car is in control and others clamp down
on it my guess is you're a clamper am i
on to it yes okay yes
so yeah
here's the beautiful thing
our bodies get addicted to that clamp
it surges
with all sorts of stress hormones and it
gets addicted to it and the sucky thing
about anxiety is when those alarms start
they start looking for everywhere we
don't have control we're not safe
yeah and then it i called it the great
transference my when i had it super bad
it would just move from thing to thing
to thing and i would eventually solve
for that thing and then it would just
move to something else
it would go from the stock market's
collapse and we're gonna have to eat our
pets too then it would move over to
climate stuff and then it would move
over to this and it kept moving on me it
would never stop
and then a real thing would happen
and then finally my body would go oh we
know this script
so am i am i reading it am i walking
down the light so it goes from
trauma real trauma relational trauma and
you're out of control then your body
sounds the anxiety alarms and then it
picks up in all kinds of
ptsd it just experiences your past
trauma in the present all day every day
you're having all these thoughts over
and over you're replaying everything and
trying to gain control over something
that happened a long time ago
and then you get covered
and you did everything right you tried
to control it you got the vaccine you've
been taking care of everything you're
being safe and you got it anyway
and now what happened is your body
realizes one damning thing
you're in control of basically nothing
nothing yeah
and it either you either let go of that
steering wheel or you uber clamped on it
and now you don't want to touch a
doorknob a button and there's a lot of
semantics in the ocd world
um about is it an anxiety disorder
different part of your brain i don't
care about any of that crap
it's it's a in as far until somebody
proves me otherwise it's a continuity it
is when your body says oh you're not
getting our message we'll take over for
you
right
and we will make sure you can't get out
of this build we want you to be so safe
that we're just gonna walk you in a
circle for the rest of your life right
yeah that's what it feels like yeah yeah
and so here's all for exposure therapy
here's all exposure therapy is let's say
you have a phobia of snakes
and if you get around snakes your body
re like you'll vomit it will lock down
not like i hate snakes but it shuts down
your body
expose your therapies when you go to
counseling and somebody will sit with
you and they will on the other side of
the room show you a picture of a snake
that's it
and they will let you'll feel your body
did you go through all this
i haven't done it yet okay
so in that you start with a picture and
then you go progressively until you've
got a snake around your neck and you're
just holding it and your body quits
reacting for you and we think it's about
thinking it's not it's about our body
taking over and all exposure therapy
does is it it it lets our body
reconnect and go okay we're safe
and by the way when you're doing this
you're working with a counselor and
you're establishing a relationship your
body is reconnecting with the human and
so you begin to over time your body goes
okay we're safe they're safe they're
safe they're safe just establishes trust
and then your body quits overreacting
and so technically that's exposure
therapy a lot of people try to go home
and would use your words which are
um
willpower i'm just gonna keep grabbing
this doorknob over and over and then i'm
just gonna lick my hand after i'm gonna
lick the doorknob
and i'm gonna go stick my hand in the
bathroom in a gas station and then i'm
just gonna eat right i mean like
what i'll tell you if you do that your
brain will revolt
yeah that's not willpower is the worst
so when i somebody tells me they try to
just grit their way through ocd grit
their way through anxiety
that is
that is
bringing a a malt like a what do you
call them a molotov cocktails i say it
too to try to put a fire out it's nuts
it's the exact wrong thing here's where
willpower works
if you will commit to submitting to this
thing
okay so it's reverse you don't want to
overdo it you almost want to underdo it
you want to get a complete submission to
it
so i've had every and the reason i'm all
man i feel like i'm talking too much i
i'm all passionate about this because
i've been down this road i was
vaccinated and i got it too i had a
breakthrough case too it was a mild case
and it was it was hard it was hard yeah
it it made me bonkers right
yeah
especially you know i'm really
extroverted
and
to be stuck inside for 14 days yep
i mean i just
mentally it was
the hardest thing i ever did yeah but
it's hard because you're
you're a clincher
yeah right you're a grasper you want to
control it through force
and anxiety loves that it just but it
makes the anxiety loop spin faster and
faster and faster
and so
this isn't all i mean it's an old
meditation practice
the practice you have ahead of you is
letting go
not okay not pushing through
i guess my question is
if i don't force myself to
touch door knobs and do things that make
me
extremely uncomfortable
how do i oh i want you to you're gonna
you're gonna do that you will okay but i
want you to do it a different way
okay so here's a couple of things you've
already you noted it a little bit your
body will relax
when it realizes it is not in danger of
germs it will over time it will
um your body's
so i want you to make peace with your
body and don't go to war with it
all your body's trying to do is keep you
safe
and it doesn't think it lived through a
pretty traumatic situation as a child
it lived through a really traumatic
situation with your
uh partner like an abusive addictive
relationship
and so your body thinks that you don't
know what you're doing that you're not a
good driver and it's gonna drive for you
okay
so i want you to make peace with your
body that's trying to help you out and
stop fighting it
ptsd is about trying to continue a war
that's already over
so yeah because i'm just always reliving
it yes so
as soon as you can make peace with the
fact that the war is over your body will
go back to it doesn't want to fight
it just feels like it has to
and you caitlyn are not um taking care
of us and so we're just gonna fight for
you and so
make peace with your body all it's
trying to do is keep you safe
and that safety
uh it's like smoking right it feels good
at 10 15 in the morning and
you got friends
and you got
you know um
it helps you feel a little better and it
kills you next year but right now it
helps that's what this is doing okay so
two things number one when you come to
the door i want you to
come to the door
and say i'm gonna practice that's the
magic word practice not fight practice
okay all right
and your body will gear up and i want
you to go oh man thank you for taking
care of me this whole thing is about
posture the behavior is going to be very
similar but it's all about posture
you're trying to take care of me i
appreciate that
i'm going to touch this doorknob now
and we're not gonna die
and the whole time i want you breathing
this thing okay
and then i want you to touch that door
and hop
or i want you to push the button
let me ask you really quick though okay
after i touch the doorknob
do i immediately sanitize my hands which
is my current instinct or do i also
let that go and just be like
well we're okay
you're gonna practice and so let's say
you cut in this i mean it could be about
50 different things it could be about
the doorknob so you touch that doorknob
and then you hold it and then i want you
to let go of that doorknob and i want
you to feel your hand
for the first time again and you've
heard me say jocko calls it detachment
if you're a navy seal and michael singer
who's like a
a great guru says it you know it's
mindfulness i want you to feel your hand
and i want you to ask your buddy what
are you doing right now
because you're not helping body like
what are we doing and i want what you're
doing is you're separating yourself from
your feelings and we're so overdriven
with our feelings we feel like we have
to respond to them our feelings often
don't tell us the truth so we've got to
acknowledge them and then we got to
decide so you're going to touch that
thing and then literally look at your
hand and go okay body what are we doing
and when you do that your body goes oh
she's driving now we're good
and it may you may say all right we're
gonna do this for 30 seconds i'm gonna
sit here for 30 seconds and i'm gonna
feel like an idiot but i'm gonna sit
here for 30 seconds and then i'm gonna
go sanitize my hands
and the practice part is there's not a
failure here
the practice is i'm gonna go for 30
seconds that's it
and i'm gonna you hear my voice like i'm
just gonna be curious about my body i'm
not gonna go to war with myself because
it's trying to help
and then tomorrow i'm gonna try a minute
or tomorrow i'm gonna go 15 seconds and
then in a week you're going to be
exhausted
and probably had too much to drink the
night before and you're gonna try it and
it's gonna be awful
and you're just gonna push the button
and go through you didn't fail anything
you're just practicing i missed the shot
that's all right i'll take another shot
tomorrow
and you're gonna lean into the practice
here
what you have to teach your body is no
we are not in control and that's okay
it's okay
we're doing the best we can with the
information we got i got vaccinated i
thought that was the right thing to do i
did it and i still got sick i got less
sick maybe i got sick and i'm gonna go
on to the next thing and your body will
learn with you
so this is going to sound bonkers
you're going to take control by letting
control go
okay okay
you are going to teach your body yes we
are not in control and yes that's okay
there is five or six things that we can
control and i'm gonna triple down on
those
i will not hang out with addicts i will
make sure i'm eating right and taking
care of my body and exercising and those
things that help with anxiety way
upstream i am going to be disciplined i
am going to read
and when crap happens i'm going to smile
about it and then get on to the next
thing
that's what we're that's what we're
working towards
okay
yeah cause those are all the things that
i i know i know i know i've not done
so
we're gonna go all the way upstream
create a world where anxiety can't exist
because your body will know oh no she's
driving and she's a good driver she's a
great driver
and we're going to create a world that
when it hits
and i hope you never get rid of anxiety
it's good for you it lets you know
you're not okay or it signals to you you
need to take a break or you got to be
around people or you got to get back in
the gym or don't eat a box of twinkies
anymore because it doesn't feel good it
will it's a good signal for you
but it will begin to ring when it's
appropriate not just all of the freaking
time
you're right in the right path so
practice be curious
and the goal here is
really begin to refine what you can
control and what you can't
and i'm telling you i've lived it
anxiety will
it will dissipate it'll show back up
when it needs to but it will dissipate
i think you can get here without
medicine i really do i really really do
if you can go see your doctor it's all
right again we're practicing we're
leaning into it and it's going to be all
good dude you're a rock star katelyn i'm
glad you're feeling better lean into it
man and
your willingness to ask
to be to be brave here is going to help
a bunch of people i'm grateful for you